et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Jean-François Copé bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous mère les
républicains de Mauves vous êtes avec
nous pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Stéphane
Vernet de westfrance bonjour Stéphane
bonjour bonjour on va parler évidemment
de l'actualité de votre partie
Jean-François Copé les républicains qui
ont donc un nouveau président Éric
Ciotti est-ce que vous resterez dans ce
parti pourquoi est-ce que je partirai il
y a eu des départs il y en a qui ne sont
pas d'accord avec la ligne d'érections
est de savoir quelle ligne on construit
après cette élection que c'est une
élection tout à fait tout à fait digne
entre des candidats qui se sont donnés
beaucoup de mal pour faire campagne je
veux dire dans des conditions difficiles
parce que l'opinion publique ne s'y est
pas du tout intéressé et il est vrai que
sa témoigne du fait que tout est à
reconstruire le vrai sujet aujourd'hui
c'est quelle ligne politique mais vous
pensez pouvoir reconstruire à
l'intérieur des républicains
le fait que le score soit assez serré
c'est c'est un problème pas du tout
est-ce que ça peut durer de l'écriture
problème
en soi le le PSG c'est ce que ça dit le
voici c'est ce que c'est ça quoi
justement alors moi je suis pas je suis
pas un expert absolu en polytologie mais
j'ai j'ai lu un certain nombre de
commentaires qui m'ont paru assez
pertinent je pense que le score est en
réalité beaucoup plus serré qu'on
pouvait le penser en fait parce que
qu'on le veuille ou non 47 53 c'est
quand même pas très loin du 55 ans et
donc
Merry Ciotti a gagné et et c'est
évidemment super pour lui mais en même
temps il ne peut pas ne pas entendre que
pratiquement la moitié de ceux qui se
sont exprimés n'ont pas voté pour lui au
deuxième tour donc donc il va falloir
composer c'est une évidence et il va
falloir composer en essayant de
décrypter qu'est-ce qui fait que celui
qui était le FA et tout le monde le
savait en l'occurrence Éric Ciotti n'a
pas fait un score plus important bon
pourquoi selon vous il y a plein
d'éléments ce qui est sûr c'est que il y
avait un affichage très clair entre Éric
cioti et Laurent Wauquiez tous les
militants et lecteurs le savent pour
autant ça n'a pas déterminé leur choix
bon donc ce qui prouve bien que tout le
discours qui a consisté à dire on
choisit tout de suite notre candidat on
veut pas de primaire on veut que ce soit
leur invoquée n'a satisfait que un petit
peu plus de la moitié des militants bon
donc ça pour moi c'est un vrai message
dont vous moi j'ai pas appris position
dans cette
pauvreté je l'ai d'ailleurs dit parce
que j'ai considéré que il y avait une
autre il y a une autre voix possible je
continue de la défendre vous le savez on
parlera peut-être mais voilà donc après
il y avait un sujet par rapport aux
positionnement vis-à-vis de on tourne
pas la page vis-à-vis Nicolas Sarkozy
bon sur ce point là aussi je vois bien
que la ligne qui a été défendue par
Bruno a quand même été entendu sur ces
sujets donc tout ça de mon point de vue
nécessite quand même qu'il y ait
d'écoute quand même de part et d'autre
pour qu'on soit clair pour vous ça veut
dire qu'il faut tourner la page de
Nicolas Sarkozy ou pas mais ça c'est un
autre sujet
non mais moi personnel
comme vous le savez je suis quand même
en rupture depuis très longtemps avec
Nicolas Sarkozy pour toute une série de
raisons donc je peux pas vous dire que
je sois d'une très grande objectivité
mais la seule chose la seule chose qui
est sûr c'est que les choix qu'il a fait
présidentiel vis-à-vis de Valérie
Pécresse de mon point de vue
l'ont rendu complètement à l'extérieur
de de
sa famille politique c'est un choix
assez délibéré qu'il a fait et donc ça
dit tout et effectivement ça tourne des
facto la page mais les militants
s'opposent encore la question vraiment
de savoir si il y a une proximité ou un
avenir commun avec Nicolas Sarkozy
l'autre chose que vous nous dites ça dit
aussi quelque chose de Laurent Wauquiez
est-ce que pour vous Laurent Wauquiez le
bon candidat à la présidentielle en 2027
je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce choix n'est
absolument impossible à faire enfin il
est pas responsable c'est trop tôt
d'abord parce que c'est trop tôt si
parce que ça n'existe pas qu'il y a pas
de débat au sein d'une famille politique
c'est pas possible on peut pas juste
dire bah je vais le faire j'ai décidé je
choisis enfin ça n'existe pas d'autant
que lui-même a fait le choix de ne même
pas présider sa famille politique donc
en réalité les cartes se sont
extrêmement ouvertes et puis encore une
fois le véritable sujet c'est pas de
désigner notre candidat pour 2027 c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait jusqu'en 2027
calendrier c'est une question de
personnes c'est une question de ligne
politique puis c'est une question de
rapport au pays aussi enfin j'ai on peut
pas juste décréter qu'on va se refaire
elle est aujourd'hui c'est devenue
malheureusement fut le premier à le
regretter moi qui est présidé cette
famille politique à un moment les avions
près de 300 à 400 000 militants
sympathisants engagés c'était au moment
de la vague bleue des municipales la
dernière grande élection qu'on ait
gagnée aujourd'hui on est plus du tout
là dedans donc notre vrai sujet il est
pas simplement de dire je jure qu'on va
gagner c'est c'est de reconstruire
pierre par pierre une maison qui s'est
effondrée il y aura malgré tout il y
aura malgré tout débat en interne autour
de la candidature de Laurent voquier
elle est pas actée comme ça en un
claquement de doigts mais je pense que
primaire mais il y aura peut-être
d'autres formations de consulter les
militaires je pense que en réalité des
facto le score de cette élection
impose qu'on ouvre tous les débats sur
ces sujets modalités désignation choix
du campus ou des candidats calendriers
et encore une fois je le répète avant
tout ça quelle ligne politique donc on
va parler de la ligne pour vous ce score
c'est aussi un refus de Laurent Wauquiez
vous l'interprétez comme ça ce que je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure c'est qu'en
tout cas ce choix là ne fait pas
l'unanimité on peut pas dire ça après on
aura des discussions j'imagine mais
c'est ça qui est aujourd'hui sur la
ligne politique est-ce que pour vous
Eric se tient incarne la droite des
complexer
la droite des complexer vous savez c'est
moi qui ai inventé le concept donc
Julien inventé sur une ligne qui était
extrêmement claire qui consistait à dire
faut arrêter d'avoir des complexes avec
la gauche il y a pas les gentils de
gauche et les méchants de droite et
d'autant qu'aujourd'hui la réalité des
attentes des Français elles sont sur les
valeurs de droite et notamment les
questions de sécurité
d'autorité mais aussi d'efficacité de
l'État et de progrès progrès économique
progrès social progrès scientifique
c'est ça qui fait l'ADN de la droite des
complexée à une condition c'est une
étanchéité complète avec l'extrême
droite quand je dis étanchéité complète
c'est complète bon et là vous avez un
dosage aujourd'hui elle est pas
complètement sécurisé cette étanchéité
bon donc à l'évidence ce débat là il est
sur la table et il faut pas penser que
tous les gens qui pensent comme moi sont
forcément partis de LR il y en a un
certain nombre qui sont à LR et qui
partagent exactement mon point de vue et
qui pour autant ne considère pas que
c'est soit vous êtes d'accord avec cette
absence d'étanchéité soit vous partez
vous parlez
vous parlez d'étanchéité à quel moment
est-ce que le le bateau républicain
pourrait prendre l'eau est-ce que les le
résultat aux européennes par exemple la
façon dont les LR vont se positionner et
peuvent gagner ou prendre ou encaisser
une nouvelle défaite pour être
déterminant dans une bascule vers vers
le rassemblement national c'est pas
est-ce que LR prend l'eau
les républicains vont le parti va très
très mal à force d'accumuler des
défaites successives parce qu'on n'a pas
réussi à être vraiment très clair sur un
certain nombre de sujets ça peut être la
défaite de trop pas plus je sais pas les
défaites de trop le le comme on dit en
microéconomie le le coût marginal de la
défaite supplémentaire il est il est
temps quand même hein bon donc qu'est-ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui nous sommes
dans une situation où faut avoir une
ligne claire nous incarnons pas une
alternance digne de ce nom parce que
nous pensons un peu comme dans le film
de mon petit python il y a très
longtemps vous avez un gars qui bloque
la forêt de Sherwood devant toute
l'armée sauf qu'ils ont lui couper un
bras deux bras les deux jambes et puis
dit mais match nulles bah non et puis
évidemment la forêt de Sherwood elle est
conquise bon donc on ne se refera pas ça
n'est pas vrai si on veut se refaire il
faut recomposer complètement en tenant
compte d'une réalité politique c'est que
le match il est entre les parties de
gouvernement et il est parti extrémistes
il n'est pas de se dire qu'est-ce qu'on
fait on est au milieu j'ai utilisé une
formule qui a un peu vexé certains je le
regrette enfin aujourd'hui on est la
tranche de jambon dans le sandwich c'est
à dire qu'on est on est totalement
inaudible à ne plus savoir à quel moment
on soutient les textes on les soutient
pas or la ligne de conduite elle est
claire on doit soutenir des textes qui
correspondent à ce que nous défendons
depuis des années sur ces sujets nous ne
pouvons pas être ambigu et le
rendez-vous des retraites est un
rendez-vous majeur de ce point de vue
c'est-à-dire que les républicains
doivent soutenir la réforme des
retraites pour vous bah ça dépend ce
qu'elle sera enfin si le gouvernement
enfin écoutez ne pas voter une réforme
de la retraite à 65 ans alors que nous
défendons cette idée depuis toujours
nous discrédit à jamais mais ça nous
discréditerait à jamais ça n'a aucun
sens quand j'entends que certains disent
qu'ils vont même déposer une motion de
censure mais c'est une folie c'est une
folie pourquoi cette folie je pense que
malheureusement ce gouvernement
multiplie les rendez-vous manqués qu'il
n'y a pas de grandes réformes qui sont
sur la table depuis que Monsieur Macron
est à l'Élysée quoi qu'il en dise parce
qu'il a reculé surtout et notamment sur
les sujets régaliens donc nous devons
nous incarner le régalien point numéro
un point numéro 2 sur les retraites ce
sera peut-être s'il l'a fait la seule
grande réforme de ces 10 années de
présidence la seule grande réforme celle
que nous attendons pour le bien de la
France depuis des années et on va pas la
voter et on va dire quoi aux Français
républicains sur notre antenne disait
mais moi j'aimerais que l'objectif ça
s'asse 63 ans à la fin du quinquennat
c'est à dire 63 ans en 2027 pour vous ça
va passer loin vous dites NON c'est 65
ans vous comprendriez pas que les
républicains de votre pas 65 ans
nous défendons le courage en politique
notre notre ADN c'est de dire aux
Français notre rôle la grandeur de la
politique c'est pas de faire ce que ce
qui fait plaisir à court terme c'est ce
qui est nécessaire pour l'avenir du pays
et pour l'avenir de nos enfants et nous
on va dire comme c'est Macron qui
propose on va pas le voter j'ai entendu
dire qu'on allait même j'ai entendu le
peut être censuré le gouvernement mais
attendez donc ça veut dire donc on va
censurer le gouvernement sur la seule
réforme dont nous-même considérons du
point de vue économique et social
qu'elle est majeure mais qui peut
entendre ça c'est pas possible ça n'est
pas responsable est-ce que pardon
Stéphane est-ce que vous demandez encore
un pacte de gouvernement est-ce que ça
vous paraît encore possible c'est juste
Stéphane séjourner dans Le Parisien qui
est qui est le patron en de renaissance
disait l'élection d'erikiotti marque un
coup d'arrêt à un éventuel accords
d'appareil vous vous entendez ça je l'ai
lu comme tout le monde mais je pense que
tout le monde pour ceux que ça intéresse
honnêtement une personne malheureusement
ne s'intéresse à tout ça
la politique passionnelle et française
constituaient les sujets des déjeuners
de famille faut plus se faire aucune
illusion maintenant tout ça n'intéresse
absolument plus les Français qui sont
écœurés des abusé et je peux pas leur
donner tort donc en l'occurrence cette
déclaration de Monsieur séjourné pardon
de vous dire mais elle n'a aucun sens
enfin on verra bien un gouvernement qui
est à la godie qui fait ce qui peut pour
essayer de trouver des députés qui
veulent bien voter ces textes et sinon
comme j'ai de faire du 49-3 ne peut pas
se payer le luxe de dire je ne veux pas
des républicains enfin ça n'a aucun sens
ils vont pas commencer à les trier il
faut arrêter avec cette arrogance c'est
un des péchés originels du macronisme
cette idée on est jeune on est frais on
est printanier tous ceux qui étaient
avant étaient nuls on va leur montrer ce
que c'est que la vie comment vous dire
c'est plus compliqué que ça la vie
juste pour revenir sur la retraite une
question François Bayrou c'est exprimé
enfin en fin de en fin de semaine en
disant qu'il est pas suffisamment de de
pédagogie autour de autour du sujet des
retraites est-ce que vous partagez cette
avis pas du tout est-ce qu'on a
suffisamment expliqué les enjeux cette
réforme aux Français mais bien sûr et il
est parfaitement compris donc il faut
arrêter de prendre les français pour ce
qu'ils sont pas moi le numéro de on a
des grèves parce qu'on a pas assez
expliqué c'est comme c'est l'occasion de
le dire je vais commencer à être un peu
expérimenté dans surtout ces sujets donc
en réalité j'ai vécu depuis
j'ai vécu toute une série d'épisodes de
réforme de Grey de réformes de retraite
avec des grèves donc je vois bien de
quoi il s'agit la seule chose que je
puisse vous dire les Français ils sont
bien au courant ils se trouvent que pour
toute une série de raisons beaucoup
d'entre eux ne sont pas d'accord avec
cette idée parce que pour des raisons
très légitimes bah ils disent j'en ai
assez je vais pas moi devoir travailler
plus etc bon bah oui mais vous avez bien
compris qu'ils étaient radicalement
qu'ils ont bien compris ils étaient tout
à fait opposés à ça reste que comment on
fait du coup et ben on a un rendez-vous
avec sa conscience c'est ce qui fait la
grandeur de la politique c'est que il y
a aussi des millions de Français qui
savent que la raison c'est aussi de le
faire pour leurs enfants parce que sinon
c'est les enfants qui payeront à leur
place donc on peut avoir un troisième
tour dans la rue qui soit assez costaud
à la rentrée autre chose
les 3e tour ce que vous appelez 3e tour
dans la rue c'est malheureusement le
rituel très français on trouve ça nulle
part ailleurs en Europe et qui fait
partie de de cette espèce de de de
dynamique infernale qui empêche les
gouvernements courageux de faire des
réformes bon encore une fois c'est pas
par plaisir on préférerait continuer de
faire ce qu'a fait le gouvernement
d'ailleurs dès le début de ce
quinquennat 20 milliards d'euros de
dépenses publiques supplémentaires pour
le pouvoir d'achat ça personne ne peut
être contre mais le rendez-vous avec les
Français ça rendait vous de conscience
parce que tout le monde est bien au
clair sur ces éléments quand vous êtes
dans un pays qui a la chance formidable
de ne pas avoir à payer pour un vaccin
contre le covid c'est bien alors que
tous les autres pays c'était payant
idem pour les tests ça dit quoi ça dit
si nous voulons continuer de préserver
cette se confort exceptionnel en matière
sanitaire alors même que l'hôpital est
en crise et qu'il va falloir le réformer
nous avons besoin de moyens
supplémentaires comment va le trouver on
peut pas le trouver sur de la dette il
faut le trouver sur des réformes de
structure et nous savons que la première
réforme c'est de travailler plus plus
longtemps c'est pas par plaisir il y a
des tas de gens qui ont envie de
s'arrêter je peux l'entendre même si je
peux entendre aussi qu'on aime son
travail mais dans tous les cas de figure
la nation ne peut plus se le permettre
bon et voyez je suis républicain de
droite je le dis aujourd'hui je l'ai dit
quand j'étais ministre du Budget je
pense que c'est une la grandeur de la
politique voilà donc ne pas le faire
c'est être irresponsable or la droite de
gouvernement elle se veut responsable
donc dire qu'elle va censurer le
gouvernement sur cette réforme mais
c'est incompréhensible
redonnera pas l'accès pouvoir
contrairement à ceux qui le pense
Emmanuel Macron a eu raison de reporter
la présentation de la réforme vous
parlez de courage politique est-ce que
vous y voyez en début de recul
j'espère que c'est pas un début de recul
parce que déjà que ce fait ça fait 5 ans
qui recule si il recule encore bon alors
quand ça cette idée de penser qu'il va
sauver les fêtes de Noël et qui aura pas
de Grèce je crois qu'il se fait de
grandes illusions malheureusement les
grèves elles sont lancées
j'ai compris que c'était pour que les
gens s'énervent pas à Noël mais des gens
vont s'énerver à Noël puisque ça y est
la SNCF Air France qui a reçu par
ailleurs un très joli chèque de l'État
va annoncé également que quand il dit
qu'il veut se donner quelques semaines
pour discuter avec les les présidents de
parti nouvellement élus à qui il pense
je sais pas il m'a entendu
ericsiotique des Parker le sujet il est
pas possible
qui a été élu président du pays que les
Parker le sujet aussi ça pour le coup
l'un comme l'autre c'est pas des gens du
nouveau monde ils ont connaissent bien
l'histoire de le président spelloy dans
l'oeil il y aura pas de négociation
possible
je vous laisse votre formule moi c'est
une question mais qui est assez drôle
d'ailleurs mais mais la vérité c'est que
la vérité c'est que surtout il y a il y
a un espèce de petit refus d'obstacles
oui ça c'est sûr oui bien sûr
ce gouvernement c'est-à-dire que d'un
côté on nous explique qu'ils incarnent
le courage qui est dès qu'ils vont aller
à l'obstacle en fait on a un peu
réfléchi on a piscine on reviendra la
semaine prochaine ça devient compliqué
quand même justement puisque vous parlez
d'Hervé Marseille qui est le nouveau
président du D est-ce que pour vous les
républicains doivent toujours être le
parti de la droite et du centre parce
que Erik sotti il est plutôt sur une
ligne droite
on se connaît bien vous savez avec nos
amis de l'UDI on fait des alliances
électorales on discute on négocie un peu
dans la grande tradition de la
République voilà donc nous on a toujours
dit qu'on était un peu parti de de
droite et du sol on veut surtout de
droite eux ils disent qu'ils sont ils
sont plutôt du centre enfin ils sont
quand même assez à droite quand même bon
voilà pas grave bon vous vous restez au
sein du parti c'est pas le cas tout le
monde il y a eu des départs ces
dernières heures il y a eu François
Grosdidier le maire de Metz il y a eu
d'autres mères d'Épinal la mère de
Manosque la mère de Barcelonnette est-ce
que pour vous c'est un épiphénomène ou
c'est un début de vague
mais je sais rien mais c'est pas
aujourd'hui je suis pas je suis pas venu
avec une boule de cristal pour moi le
sujet il est surtout de savoir si la
nouvelle équipe autour d'erikiotips qui
va constituer évidemment j'imagine une
nouvelle équipe que cette équipe soit en
situation de proposer une ligne
politique s'arrête pas à des
désignations de personnes ou d'une
personne pour la présidentielle voilà
c'est tout ce que je dis c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire comment on se positionne
avec avec
la majorité actuelle et avec les
extrêmes voilà c'est tout
c'est pas sécurisé l'autre question
c'est est-ce que Édouard Philippe est le
gagnant de cette élection est-ce que
vous pensez que l'élection à la tête
derrière va renforcer horizon
très complexe à résoudre aussi faut pas
se raconter des blagues d'abord parce
qu'il a peu de députés parce qu'il a il
a bizarrement négocié donc il a qu'une
vingtaine de députés deuxième
membre enfin j'étais pas en charge de ça
enfin j'aurais peut-être pas fait comme
ça deuxièmement deuxièmement dans la vie
il faut s'imposer quoi donc il va
falloir qu'il s'impose lui aujourd'hui
il a une grande difficulté aujourd'hui
on le voit bien or il y a besoin
d'entendre une forte que cette parole
forte soit incarnée elle soit relayée
soit organisée après vous savez moi j'ai
été élevé à l'école Jacques Chirac une
école Jacques Chirac c'est une école où
on est au quotidien avec ses troupes
avec aller en chercher des nouvelles à à
prendre son téléphone pour appeler les
gens et pas simplement attendre qu'ils
viennent vers vous enfin bon c'est tout
c'est un métier quoi donc vous rejoindre
horizon à un moment non en fait non mais
d'ailleurs ce personne spéciale
son téléphone
ça fait déjà trois ou quatre fois que
vous me demandez si toi partir de là
un pack de gouvernement une alimentation
moi j'ai proposé une coalition surtout
pas des des des débauchages individuels
manifestement d'après ce que vous venez
de nous dire vous ne croyez pas trop à
l'hypothèse et devoir Philippe à
l'Elysée en 2022
pour tout le monde et moi je suis un bon
spécialiste je me suis préparé pendant
des années et puis j'ai vu que
finalement les circonstances ne me le
permettaient pas donc du coup j'ai bien
compris que c'est pour ça que je me
transforme un peu en coach maintenant
oui je partage donc je dis pas qu'elle
est haute pour lui je qu'elle est tout
court à deux dernière question sur un
autre sujet évidemment au sujet de
préoccupation des Français c'est la
question des
oses des prix des prix de l'énergie et
de l'électricité puisque le gouvernement
prépare à d'éventuels coupures à
d'éventuelles coupures d'électricité
est-ce que le maire que vous êtes est
suffisamment préparé est-ce que vous
avez suffisamment d'informations est-ce
que vous avez suffisamment de
préparation
non non d'ailleurs un mot les gens s'en
inquiètent beaucoup on en parle
énormément
[Musique]
sujet c'est que moi j'ai réduit
considérablement un certain nombre de
dépenses énergétiques je les dis
d'ailleurs à mes administrés notamment à
la période de Noël
traditionnellement une patinoire on
n'aura pas de patinoire on a réduit un
certain nombre de d'événements on est on
est obligé de le faire bon sur les
histoires de délestage tout le monde est
évidemment inquiet puis moi ce que ce
qui moi m'intéresse beaucoup dans les
conversations que j'ai pas qu'à moi mais
beaucoup à mot c'est sûr tant que mère
c'est que les gens ont compris une chose
ce choix de renoncer au nucléaires était
une folie une folie et je vois les
responsables politiques responsables de
ça ce débiner lamentablement il n'y a
plus un qui était concerné qui a le plus
de la faute de personnes Monsieur
Hollande monsieur Macron leur ministre
de l'Écologie de l'Énergie respective
personne n'était au courant qu'on
arrêtait qu'ils avaient donné des ordres
d'arrêter le nucléaire bon donc c'est ça
qu'on paye aujourd'hui et c'est rentable
c'est encore une fois la démonstration
que quand on tombe sur des effets de
mode généralement prenez par des vers
qui se préoccupent pas tellement de la
question écologique mais plutôt de
déstabiliser l'état on a des résultats
qui sont catastrophiques et sur le
chèque de dans un dans le même registre
sur le chèque de 100 euros pour les 10
millions de travailleurs modeste qui ont
besoin qui ont besoin de faire le plein
c'est ce que ça c'est un bon choix pour
vous bref c'est encore un succès d'année
qui n'a pas de sens c'est un milliard
d'euros quand même parce que c'est pas
un chèque de 100 euros c'est un chèque
de 1 milliard d'euros
on dit un milliard ça peut être un
milliard et demi pour les ménages ça
fait ça fait 100 euros oui ça fait 100
euros donc c'est pertinemment que en une
fois ça nous couvrira jamais
suffisamment les besoins et que c'est
pas une dynamique positive c'est 100
euros voilà et en réalité ça ne
correspond absolument pas une réforme
rien faire c'est ça vous savez c'est
c'est tellement la facilité votre
question je veux dire ça mais c'est la
fête si je vous dis oui bah vous voulez
me dire OK
je vous dis non si je vous dis non et
bien bah vraiment c'est la dureté de la
droite bon donc la vérité c'est que la
raison et qu'il faut des réformes de
structure et qu'il faut évidemment
développer toutes les sources d'énergie
qui nous permettent d'éviter d'avoir un
chat à faire un chèque d'un milliard
d'euros sur le dos du contribuable
d'aujourd'hui des enfants demain avec
les dettes merci Jean-François Copé
merci beaucoup
d'avoir merci beaucoup
dans le ton poisson merci Jean-François
Copé on passe au clavier
[Applaudissements]